bonjour ma très chère amie bonjour
monsieur 19 vous allez bien très bien je
vous remercie voilà j'ai une demande
refaire mais je vous en prie de quoi
s'agit-il c'est très simple voilà je
vous ai vu danser dernièrement avec
casimir et
j'aimerais beaucoup d'anciens décrire ce
serait avec un très grand plaisir
seulement aux je tremble ne soyez pas
trop cruel je vous en prie
oui seulement casimir et mois avant
d'arriver à danser nous avons beaucoup
travaillé nous avons fait des heures
d'exercices au sol à la plagne au repos
et puis un choix de la musique la
chorégraphie tout cela représente des
heures de travail je vous parle et hop
les illustres représentants de nos
enfants
ne se laissent pas le président de la
fat de nos enfants vous l'avez oublié 20
ans je n'ai pas oublié
d'ailleurs je ne risque pas de luri vous
le répéter tout le temps dites moi mais
c'est dix neuf qu'en fait ce rêve ou
d'être aussi prétentieux ainsi nous
mangera mimoun éducation ou en savoir
manger jeudi dont l'assainissement de
l'eau sont moins chers amis et j'y lis
tu m'avais promis dennis fait un jeu
avec moi et je t'attends tu sais il
c'est à dire non non j'ai dit tu vas pas
encore me dire que tu as trop de travail
à faire non non non bien sûr c'est moins
cher ami ma danse notre danse quoique tu
as première année chez du snep de danse
yannick est parfaitement et la première
chaire ami adnan ajoute avec un très
grand plaisir mais en moi aussi monsieur
du snav elle a promis mais oui oui là et
la famille de venir faire un jeu avec
moi les enfants qu'ils attendent
pas du
tout mais loin de nous l'idée dû
disparaître
faute
mais bien sûr j'ai lu enfin tu n'auras
jamais dû promettre ton après-midi à
monsieur du snob et à moi-même tu auras
bravache et à midrand pulsations choisi
la même chose la même circonstance
tout ça suffit 1 je ne vous ai rien
promis c'est vous qui avez imaginé tous
les dieux que vous alliez passer
l'après-midi avec moi et bien dans ces
conditions je ne passerai l'après midi
ni avec l'un ni avec l'autre je ferme
mon kiosque vous vous arrangerez tous
les deux
salut
salut ne reste pas au moins sur une
chaîne fois que tu arrives qu'il est on
à ne reste pas figée plus sûrs atouts
mois moi je suis pas possible j'en ai
jamais vu dans la région était sûr que
c'était bien un rat d'abord parce que tu
sais on peut confondre 1 cela pourrait
être un écureuil qu'un impôt petit
écureuil roux avec une grande que de
fourrure qui était en train de grignoter
des noisettes non je n'étais pas un
petit écureuil
alors c'était une marmotte grise qui
regardait autour d'elle avec des yeux
étonnés
non ce n'était pas alors c'était c'était
une belette toute fille et beige clair
non non et non je te dis je vois tes
gros
attentat t'attends tu confonds avec un
blaireau qui a trois grosses taches
blanches une de chaque côté de la tête
et une troisième au dessus qui descend
dans le coup voilà les pins du tout
c'était un gros rat noir attend le monde
termine à la fourrure blanche et soyeuse
non un castor habile tu sais un casteur
avec ses pattes arrière calmer et sa
large que plate ils devaient s'activer à
ronger un tronc d'arbre takatani la fin
c'était un rat je te dis un grand et
gros rat noir tout noir qui courait dans
cette direction
là
c'est sûr
c'était pas un furet c'était pas notre
pain caster
c'était pas un écureuil
mais je ne vais pas le dire plus tôt au
score au secours au secours
[Rires]
j'ai besoin de toi
il n'est pas là cissé kazemi à casimir
je suis là mais pas françois boyer
compte c'est très grave j'ai peur de
rater un rendez vous important toi aussi
mais pourquoi moi aussi parce que je lis
a promis à monsieur du snob de danser
avec lui et à moi de faire un jeu avec
les enfants ah bon alors allez parquet
avec monsieur du soir n'ont ni avec l'un
ni avec l'autre écoute je ne comprends
rien mais ça fait rien je suis venu vous
proposer un jeu qui a servi un jeu tu un
jumeau vieux pouvoir vous entendez ça
les enfants mais c'est formidable nous
sommes sauvés casimir un jeu casimir
nous écoutons voilà alors comme vous le
savez j'ai de nombreux amis qui se
couche à l'automne pour ne se réveiller
qu'au printemps les émirs ont dit qu'ils
y berne c'est ça il hiberne alors ce qui
est grave c'est que j'ai peur de ne pas
me souvenir dans quels endroits ils ont
fait leur lit à je comprends traite
maintenant des singles nordistes ont dû
signer la supprimer je fixe des dessins
sur le tableau noir désir
regardez bien ces en six endroits les
enfants vous allez lire à casimir dans
quel endroit chacun de ses amis yb berne
et vous si chez vous vous cherchez votre
moi le jardin des amis que j'ai remis
mes bons copains il ya joe le iris en
jeu le hérisson à votre avis les enfants
ou jouer le hérisson va-t-il passer
l'hiver dans quel endroit
ici à n'ont certainement pas exactement
jouer le hérisson va passer l'hiver
rouler en boule dans un nid de pie à
bienne la chaux alors un jour lors dans
l'apparition tu ailles albert le loire
albert le loire
ah non pas dans la fissure du mur
tu as raison
le loire va passer l'hiver
caché dans un nid de branchement charge
actionner bien car il à notre copain
c'est aristide le lézard ici le lézard
vous êtes tous d'accord les encore non
dans le trou il y en a qui qui veulent
le faire qui faire passer l'hiver dans
l'arbre et les autres oppositions 2010
accor 1 la bonne réponse est dans la
fissure de l'arbre voilà et quelquefois
d'ailleurs le lézard peut se mettre
caché entre deux rochers alors le lézard
une médaille or il ya mon grand copain
l'un
l'écurie
vous avez raison l'écureuil se mettra
dans le trou danard voilà comment
s'appelle-t-il ton ami l'écureuil un
biogaz par des stars ensuite j'y mets en
coin nec la chauve-souris antoinette la
chauve-souris regardez comme elle est
drôle ici là et bien antoinette va
passer l'hiver effectivement
suspendu par les pieds la tête en bas à
la poutre d'un vieux grenier d'une
grange où vous êtes super deux fois
aussi dans une grotte casimir alors si
je la trouve pas dans mon grenier elle
sera dans une grotte d'accord exactement
il vient alors la dernière la voilà une
grenouille
le dessin n'est pas exact la grenouille
passera l'hiver dans la vase d'un
marécage
on me verra dépasser son petit museau
quand même oui mais à peine 15
merci mes amis vraiment mon mari aidez
vous êtes prêtre est très précieux merci
à à bientôt un cfc casimir merci pour
ton jeu voir
qu'est ce qu'il fait mais qu'est-ce qui
salue léonard casimir tu n'en as vu le
facteur emile campagne why toute excuse
moi mais je suis pression où vas tu je
dois aller dire au revoir à tous mes
amis qui s'apprête à passer l'hiver mais
quels amis enfin jour le hérisson marie
la grenouille marcel l'écureuil et tous
les autres en ce qui
berne
comme emploi qui prétend être le renard
savants du monde tu ne sais pas ce que
veut dire hiberner et bien non je ne
sais pas alors eh bien les animaux qui
berne sont les animaux qui passent tout
l'hiver à dormir
j'aurais plutôt appeler ça des paris sur
30 pour parlez pas j'oubliais le livre
mais quelques élèves casés mais enfin le
livre pour jour le hérisson il ne peut
pas s'endormir si je ne vais pas
raconter une histoire tu vois je
pourrais peut-être venir avec toi et lui
chanter une chanson oh quelle horreur il
fera plutôt des cauchemars oui et coûte
pourtant j'ai une belle voix et écoute
très contente a dit wang tom le chat n'a
pas touché à sympathiser horreurs
qu'elle aura un coup ça suffit tu es toi
je me demande pourquoi les renards
n'hibernent pas or au moins je passerai
l'hiver tranquille bon allez salut un
cas tout à l'heure je vais être en
retard oui c'est ça salut
ce pauvre casimir n'a vraiment aucune
kim a goûté à la pâte est déjà là moi je
trouve que ça sciemment chez une bonne
voie
par vous et ce facteur qui n'est
toujours pas là enfin
conscience
en mai que fit in c'est incroyable ils
sont tous fous dans cette île il n'en
restait plus qu'un de raisonnable émile
campagne le facteur jamais en retard
jamais un mot plus haut que l'autre
toujours gentil toujours souriant
et où mahmoud s'attend pas hop voilà il
ya 10 minutes de retard c'est incroyable
mais s'ils pensent tout à coup casimir
on a parlé plusieurs fois d'un certain
monsieur travelling imprésario je crois
peut-être raté tendu un piège
rim il peut-être se trouve-t-il en ce
moment au milieu daf de l'afrique ou du
guatemala dans une grande cage il faut
vite organiser une expédition pour le
secourir et vite le téléphone
allô françois oui c'est lui en art
j'invite chez casimir
c'est très grave ouais vite vite et
prévient julie oui
monsieur du sud
non monsieur du ce nombre il se produit
un drame essayer de trouver casimir et
et venez oui dépêchez vous c'est une
question de vie ou de mort
silence l'heure est grave
le facteur va nous chanter sa chanson
ainsi qu on se voit très gentil sa
mademoiselle julie
l'emprunteur vous faut chanter
oui ou non
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou gêne au drame
j'aurais pu même être chaud autres
j'aurais pu être plus petit bassin
confiseurs mécano
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le roi sol d'orthographe
je suis l'ami des jolis mots l'amoureux
des phrasés cv quand je les emporte sur
mon
sous la manche ont voté
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier à son rouge et au gras
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mécano bras
mais j'ai choisi d'être packtec car je
suis le roi de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres en u les écritures
gay et charmante quand leur taux grave
faire respecter cela m'enchante
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chaude
j'aurais pu être cultivé heures confie
ce fou mais cale au bras mais j'ai
choisi d'être factuel
je suis le roi de leurs programmes
dès que commence ma tournée
tout le long du chemin
je chauffe
les gens guette mon arrivée cela
montchamp
m
j'aurais pu être contre les hackers
veniez masson rouge et au gras
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mégalo
mais j'ai choisi d'être pas de fer forgé
et je choisis des tracteurs pour sur lui
mais j'ai choisi d'être un patin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]